not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter download the qurani app now and
have a ramadan with allah's book like
you've never had before
brothers and sisters and dear friends
ramadan mubarak inshallah you're having
an amazing time and make the most out of
these last 10 nights inshallah it could
be later inshallah what you're about to
watch is very disturbing and could
really really make you angry my brother
says i want you guys to channel the
anger in the right way which i'm going
to come to in a minute but this is
piccadilly circus tower table which i
know very well from muhammad ali and the
rest of the team have been going there
day in day out and i know these brothers
ok somebody can vouch for their
sincerity i can vouch meaning that
they're doing it insha'allah for the
sake of allah subhanahu wa tala from
what i can see hamdulillah and we assume
the best of the believers wallahi
brothers and sisters
they go there night and day and they get
this abuse
subhanallah watch this video inshallah
where the group of these far-right scum
dirtbags yeah coming and acting all hard
because there's a couple of them look
what happens
this person has so much hatred for islam
they threw a big foot on
subhanallah
[Music]
it is a demonic doctrine of satanic
origin that has taken you to hell
[Music]
you are root
non-doctrine
and this place shouldn't
[Music]
i haven't seen it to that degree myself
in the dial tables maybe because we
don't do that late to the night upon
allah but these brothers still
regardless of what kind of abuse they
get they carry on the tower and they
need our support guys i will never ever
ask you guys to give towards something
that i do not trust myself
these brothers i know them myself and i
believe that they are welcome to allah
and they do beautiful thou with brothers
and sisters and i believe they are
sincere subhanallah in their cause may
allah accept it from them i need you
guys please donate to their project so
they can expand the dollar tables around
london inshallah i work closely with
them and i know them subhanallah
brothers and sisters this video i want
you to channel that energy the anger
towards a good cause and give towards
this tower table inshallah and let them
carry on their work to increase the
amount of guys doing that
on the streets inshallah brothers and
sisters that's all they need may allah
deal with these guys because they're
never going to stop the dawah they are
fear they fear the quran our biggest
jihad is not the weapons of mass
destruction or weapons at all but quran
is our biggest weapon it is our biggest
weapon and we will use that till the day
we die and that's why you do not like it
and that's why you attack us you carry
and attack us you will never stop us you
are never going to stop us we are going
to carry on the message of allah and his
kalam and make his kalam the highest
inshallah with our intellectual
arguments debunking you guys one at a
time inshaallah and may allah bless
every single one of you guys for
watching and the link is in the
description box donate to this course
because
i will myself personally donating to as
well until next time assalamu alaikum
share this far and wide may allah bless
you guys until next time goodbye the
prophet
spent 13 years of his life in mecca
delivering the message of islam and
being persecuted some of his companions
were killed in their aim to deliver the
message of islam the prophet isa salaam
traveled all the way to taif and while
he was traveling they threw stones at
him and he bled until his feet were
stuck to his sandals the footage you
have seen is only some of our go through
on a daily basis fulfilling your duty as
a muslim and delivering the message of
islam they are out there five days a
week delivering the message of islam
calling people to allah and removing
misconceptions from islam
the prophet was the most generous of us
and he was the most generous in ramadan
in these last 10 nights of ramadan do
not let the shaitaan stop you from
donating do not let the shaitan stop you
from supporting kardawa hit the link
below now and donate